nadie quiere que estas escenas se
repitan en 2015 la llegada masiva de
miles de refugiados inmigrantes provocó
una crisis en la unión europea
actualmente frente al aumento del éxodo
afganos y europa las divisiones
reaparecen hace un tiempo el gobierno
afgano nos pidió a suspender los vuelos
de repatriación hasta el final de
octubre ahora estamos cumpliendo con
este pedido creo que es lo correcto un
millón de migrantes llegaron a alemania
durante la crisis migratoria de 2015
muchos de ellos eran afganos que huían
de la guerra hoy 30.000 tenían la orden
de quitar el territorio un mandato
suspendido por el momento al ser un
punto de entrada clave en el bloque
europeo grecia fue uno de los países más
afectados para dicha nación suspender
las deportaciones no era la alternativa
adecuada
topping detener el retorno de quienes no
tienen derecho a protección
internacional enviaría un mensaje
equivocado en este tiempo difícil para
afganistán podría llevar a que más
personas intenten irse y encaminarse a
la unión europea
con la salida de las tropas
internacionales de afganistán el
conflicto se exacerbó en una avanzada
relámpago los talibanes se hicieron con
el control de nueve capitales de
provincia en los últimos días
en los últimos días hemos visto una
escalada mortal de los combates en
afganistán lo que ha sumado un
sufrimiento incalculable en un país
donde más de 5 millones de personas ya
están desplazadas internamente estoy
sumamente preocupado por la situación en
particular por el impacto en las
poblaciones móviles y desplazadas una
población desesperada que tiene europa
en vilo